An artificial island that rises with the sea.
And This is NOT what you think it is!
Vsauce! Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
Several of these creatures referred to as
"blind snakes" were recently discovered in
Brazil. Engineers found the meter long creature
after draining a hydroelectric dam spanning
a river connected to the Amazon. Biologists
say that despite looking like snakes, they actually
aren't reptiles, and are more closely related
to salamanders and frogs.
Researchers at Carnegie Mellon created a snake
robot. These modular snakes can navigate a
variety of terrain from poles to networks
of pipes, allowing it access to locations that
people and machinery otherwise cannot use.
CAT TUNNEL SOFA.
If you want to interact with plants there's
botanics interacticus. The sensing technology
treats plants as an electrical circuit so
each different type of plant creates unique
interactive properties. The idea is to stretch
the limits of what we can interact with.
Using police composite sketch software and
descriptions from Bram Stoker's Dracula - this
is what it says Count Dracula looks like.
Now meet Stompy. The giant, rideable, walking
robot. This open-source, 18ft wide, 4,000
pound, 6-legged hydraulic robot is currently
in development by Project Hexapod, and if
they raise enough money they hope to build
an entire zoo of giant rideable robots.
Identifying pastries in a second is this new
point-of-sale system in Tokyo. It recognizes
shapes and colors to identify baked goods,
allowing cashiers unfamiliar with the products
to still quickly ring up items. And they say
the system could be eventually be used to
distinguish vegetables and medicine.
I'm a moth, and here I am. I'm a moth, and now
I'm a tree.
Instantly deodorizing dirty diapers is this
activated charcoal system. The material is
called mesopore activated charcoal which has
larger pores than normal charcoal to absorb
a variety of odors. And is currently developed
for hospitals, but they're working on a home
model.
Finally, Future Forms of Life is a short film
based on Theo Jansen's kinetic sculptures...
I'm gonna leave you with Fire Breathing at
2000 frames per second. And as always thanks
for watching.